♪ (UPBEAT JAZZ MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
TARAJI P. HENSON:
I brush my teeth.
I smile.
But there is always this frown.
I think I'll run away
with the ants...
and live on Mars.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
And I'm fortunate
because I'm a poet,
and poets are allowed
to be hopeful.
I used to dream radical dreams
of blowing everyone away
with my perceptive powers
of correct analysis.
I don't remember
a lot of things.
But a lot of things
that I don't remember,
I don't choose to remember.
Childhood remembrances
are always a drag
if you're Black.
I remember what's important,
and I make up the rest.
That's what storytelling's
all about.
I even used to think
I'd be the one to stop the riots
and negotiate the peace.
STUDENT: Would you ever say
that some of your poems
were inspired by stress
or hate?
STUDENT 2: Were you ever
bullied by your skin color
when you were younger?
STUDENT 3: Have you ever had,
like, a breakdown,
where you couldn't take
it anymore,
where you just couldn't do it?
But there has to be a way
to do what we do and survive.
Our ancestors taught us
how to do that.
NIKKI: The one thing
that I did know
is whatever life would be,
I knew I had to create myself.
To successfully go to Mars
and back,
you will need a song.
And maybe a six pack,
so if there is life on Mars,
you can share.
Popcorn for the celebration
when you land,
while you wait on
your land legs to kick in.
And as you climb down
the ladder from your spaceship
to the Martian surface,
look to your left,
and there you'll see
a smiling community
quilting a black-eyed pea,
watching you descend.
(CHUCKLES)